they are some of the first in a
europe-wide effort to place hundreds of
miners all of them traveling and living
without parental guidance these 47
children were headed for Germany in all
it's hoped 1,500 unaccompanied young
people will be allowed to relocate we
are striving to provide help as part of
a European solution we offered that
early on already on March the 8th the
German government decided to accept at
least 350 children from the camps five
of the children will go to new homes in
the city of Potsdam just south of Berlin
the mayor there has been demanding
action from the German government for
months because we could certainly take
in more we already said that in January
that's why for me it's a first step I'm
quite a positive person so I see it as
an initial step in getting people here
but more have to follow quickly idol
phobia indeed even if this program is
successful it will still leave more than
3,500 unaccompanied minors in the camps
the first 47 young people in the program
to touch down in Germany here in
Hannover will be quarantined before
moving on to their new lives far from
the harsh conditions of the Greek island
camps and even further from their home
countries of Syria Afghanistan Iraq and
Eritrea for more on that we're joined
now by journalists aunty Kara Sava in
Athens aunty I appreciate your being
here let me start with the first
question that jumps out for me why are
only children being moved out to the out
of the camps right well this is a plan
which the Prime Minister here kyriakos
me to attack is hatched very very early
on after his election here last year and
it has to do basically with the fact
that Greece is coping with a hundred
thousand migrants who are trapped here
in the country and resettlement and
relocation programs with Europe have
effectively halted so what he's trying
to do
with this plan is start off with the
most vulnerable lot which of course are
these unaccompanied minors and that's
what the government it's no coincidence
for example that the Prime Minister was
there today at the airport sending off
these children to Germany there were 12
more who was sent to Luxembourg just a
couple of days ago but these numbers may
sound very very small but what he's
hoping is that they can start pavely
paving the way for more relocations and
for more family unifications
reunifications many of these children
have families in the West they were
split during their harrowing journeys
from Afghanistan in Syria here I get it
I get it now now now Greece apparently
welcomed this EU initiative but what
specific measures has a country taken to
protect people living in the camps from
the pandemic
well Greece has been has taken very
effective in robust measures from the
start
I'd say actually faster than any other
EU Member State and that's why it's seen
it's the impact of the pandemic here in
Greece very very low
we've just had about a hundred deaths
here compared to the thousands and tons
of thousands that we've seen gripping
Europe as far as the refugees these
measures have applied from the start so
much more in these abysmal camps and
refugee camps there have been cases the
government has quickly isolated them and
what it has managed to do is not to
allow them to spread to further
communities within especially these
islands antiquer Sava
there in in Greece first thank you so
much